Khloe Kardashian is having so much fun
going all-out for her birthday
well all-out brunette that is I love it
the reality star hit up Instagram late
Sunday night to show off her dark sexy
new look yep that's Coco lookin straight
fire sands her signature blonde locks
she captioned the shot quote birthday
glam tomorrow I'm flooding my timeline
with party pics bTW I'm loving my brown
hair and she added that the new hue was
giving her a little something right now
yeah Chloe us too us too
and we aren't the only ones Chloe's ex
and the father of her daughter true
Tristan Thompson commented on the post
with fire heart and heart eye emojis
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
Chloe's pal Jonathan Cheban pointed out
the huge bling that she was rocking on
that finger writing does that ring come
with shades blinded by the light but
seriously anyway Chloe celebrated her
bday over the weekend with her family at
Kylie's new la mansion and it was a bash
I'm excited about it there was a giant
inflatable slide featuring Chloe's face
at the top naturally very stormy world
of her a massive balloon display and a
table full of sweets
and yes those cookies have pictures of
Chloe on them because duh Khloe's
sisters Kendall Kylie and Kourt were in
attendance and things got a little rowdy
when the girls straight-up
roughhouse in the middle of the party
[Music]
yeah things got sort of wild Chloe's
younger brother Rob was also there Rob's
doing great he really is he even posted
a few rare pics of himself celebrating
on Instagram he definitely is more
low-key than all of us and we love that
and respect that that's the 33 year old
with Scott Disick's Tristan Thompson and
Kourt we love having him around but back
to the birthday girl Chloe reflected on
the day tweeting that she had the most
magnificent birthday and she thanked her
fans for their beautiful and kind wishes
here's hoping 36 is full of family and
fun
[Music]
[Music]